there's been heavy fighting between
Russian and Ukrainian forces in bahmoud
in the Eastern Donetsk region the deputy
mayor claims Russian soldiers tried to
storm the city from several directions
he also says people are living in dire
conditions the city has been without
electricity gas and running water for
nearly two months more than 120
civilians have been killed there since
the War Began
let's bring in assadburg who is in
quivery in central Ukraine I said good
to see you bring us up to date with the
latest in fighting in bakmut
yes Bahamut has seen some of the most
intense fighting that is seen over the
last few months now we were there back
in May the Russians were trying to take
it then you're there uh just a few weeks
ago two weeks ago and again the Russians
were pushing on several different
directions to try and take that
strategic city of Bahamut if they take
it it gives them access the roads give
them access to other parts of the
country now some of the footage that
we've been seeing is of Ukrainian forces
still in that City but the buildings
around them have taken a real battering
in fact when we were there it was the
same situation a lot of the buildings
had been destroyed and as you said no
electricity water or gas now some of the
Wagner group members of the Wagner group
that private company linked to the
Kremlin have said that Russian forces
have begun to enter the city although
it's very difficult to independently
verify uh which side is correct at this
current point in time when the fighting
is so intense it's difficult to get
access to that City because it's just
too dangerous but we're also hearing
that along inside artillery fire there's
a lot of trench fighting going on as
both sides try to fortify their
positions also getting ready for the
winter
it's also been a lot of focus on the
counter offensive going on in Curson
what is the situation there
well the ukrainians say that their
counter-offensive is continuing
authorities in croissants say that
they've seen some of the most intense
artillery fire that they've seen over
the last week now the ukrainians claim
that they shut down two helicopters
although again very difficult to
independently verify the ukrainians also
say that they've destroyed Russian
vehicles resupplies and defenses as well
as a command post in the city of
military Depot now the Russians have
been evacuating civilians something a
move that Russian President Vladimir
Putin has publicly endorsed but the
ukrainians they only reports or
suggestion that the Russian forces are
withdrawing from person well are
premature they believe the Russian
forces that are withdrawing are being
replaced by other forces now karson is
very important to Russia strategically
and politically it's the only Regional
Capital they've managed to take since
the start of the war it's the only place
Russian forces occupy west of that
danipro River who have signs the gateway
to Crimea that Russia annexed back in
2014 and if is a big if at this point in
time the ukrainians managed to take her
son it will expose other Russian forces
elsewhere in the country now elsewhere
in Ukraine there was a missile strike by
the Russians in the city of zaparita
commercial building was destroyed and
one person was killed but as I say the
fighting around the East and the south
is still very intense and both sides
claiming that they've made making
advances
okay thank you for that update I said
bag in Korea in central Ukraine
meanwhile it was another night of
Darkness for the people in the capital
Kiev and seven other regions across
Ukraine after days of scheduled
blackouts the state Energy company
announced it wasn't enough it's warned
of indefinite emergency outages Russia
has repeatedly carried out missile and
drone attacks on Ukraine's power
facilities Western allies have condemned
the attacks especially in the lead up to
Winter let's go to Harry Fawcett who is
in Kiev so Harry firstly let's talk
about the blackouts what is the latest
with that have you been affected
well yes what was the original plan as
of a couple of weeks ago was that there
would be four hour long up to four hour
long scheduled blackouts uh cycling
through various parts of various
neighborhoods through the capital uh as
the situation has got worse there was
talk of those being extended uh they
don't always happen they don't always
last as long as they potentially might
but they have been getting more frequent
certainly just anecdotally here in our
neighborhood in central Kiev they've
been getting more frequent in recent
days and yes now there is this uh extra
bit of information that these could turn
into indefinite unpredictable
unscheduled blackouts because the strain
on the energy system has become so great
and that is all because of this pretty
Relentless campaign of strikes on the
energy infrastructure we were talking to
the energy Minister just the other day
he was saying that some uh important
sort of electricity nodes in the system
were being struck up to 10 times
repeatedly they get fixed and they're
struggish again and he said that this
wasn't being planned by military
Specialists this was being planned
potentially even in real time by those
with real energy expertise and
substantial knowledge of Ukraine's
Soviet era power system